[ YouTube Learning ]
Wouldn’t you love creating
ENGAGING presentations for your students?
Presentations that will make your students
fall in love with the topic?
I’m Ganesh,
I’m the founder of Don’t Memorise
and in this video,
I will teach you
the basics of creating Google Slides
in your Google Classroom!
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
After you click on a particular class,
you can click on the Classwork tab!
This is your topic,
and this is the material within the topic.
This topic already has a Google Doc file,
and now say you want to add a Google Slides
presentation to it.
To do that,
you can then click on the
3 vertical dots next to
the same material within the topic,
and click on Edit.
Just like we did with Docs,
you could either ADD
an existing Google Slides Presentation
or CREATE one.
Let’s try creating one by clicking here.
And that opens a new
Google Slides presentation for you.
It’s really easy for anyone
to create a presentation here.
First, let’s give the presentation a name...
You could then add a nice title
to your first slide
so that your students know
what the presentation is all about.
And by clicking here,
you could also see the
various themes available to you
Let’s pick this one,
and we can instantly see that it looks better.
You can also make these texts
appear in an animated way!
You can click on this text box,
go to Insert,
and select animation.
By default, this text will fade in on click.
To get a preview of how this will appear,
you can click on play...
and then click on the screen.
That’s how the text will appear.
You can also make it Fly in from the left.
You can see the preview again!
Let’s give this second object an effect too.
You can select the object...
Click on ‘Add animation’...
and you can make it fly in from the right.
You can now begin the presentation
by clicking here.
On your first click,
you will see this text,
and on your second click,
you will see this one appear.
That’s how easy it is!
And as teachers,
we often want to show videos to our students
during presentations right?
Can we do that here?
Absolutely!
Let’s first add a NEW slide...
We just click on Insert
and then on Video.
You could add a video using any of the 3 ways.
You could search on YouTube,
or you could use a link that we already have,
or you could also upload a video
you have in your Google Drive Folder.
Let me quickly show it to you.
I search for a youtube video,
select the relevant video,
and then click on Select.
You will see the video here.
Many times, we don’t really want to show
the entire video to the students.
So using the Timing option here,
we can only select the part
that we really wish to share with students.
And if you just want to share the animation,
and not the voice over,
you can even choose to
‘Mute the audio’ by clicking here.
So that’s how you can add a video
to your presentation.
But hold on,
the whole thing gets way better.
You could use Slides to give live presentations
to your students by clicking here.
You can also send the presentation directly
to all your students by clicking on the
Share button here.
Let’s present now!
And one important thing you will need
when you are giving a presentation is a Pointer.
Clicking on the Pointer option below
will help you point to certain objects or
areas on your slide.
You also have the feature to add Captions
when you are presenting your Slides.
Let’s try this out for fun.
We can position the text at the top
and select the size as Large.
Now let me start talking.
“We can learn more about this concept
using animation”...
Amazing right?
And now I come to what I think is one of the
coolest features of Google Slides.
The QNA section!
Clicking here will lead you to
an audience tool
where you can generate a link
to share with your students.
Using this link,
your students or fellow teachers
could ask you questions!
Let’s try this out.
Once the link is shared with the students,
they will see a screen like this one,
where they can ask their questions.
They could even ask it anonymously too.
Once the question is asked,
you will see it here in this section!
I know you’d be surprised to know that
so many options exist with this one simple tool.
If you practice and
get better at Google Slides,
then you could share your presentation
not only with your students but
also with the rest of the world.
Like most Google Products,
you can use Google Slides on
any smartphone, laptop or tablet.
You can even edit it while you are offline
and it will sync changes once you go online.
You would have realised that it’s so easy
and so much fun to teach your students online.
In the next video,
I will teach you how you could create
quizzes and assignments for your students
on Google Classroom.
See you there!
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]